so welcome everyone to the second day
and second quantum session of itcs
so the way we're going to do it is um
all the questions
will be reserved at the end for the
panel discussion so
if you have a question try to remember
it write it down you can put it in the
chat if you want
um and i will give a verbal one minute
reminder
to the speakers so the talk time is
eight minutes
and try to stay on schedule so
uh with that said i think the first talk
is by lior eldar who will be
telling us about robust quantum
entanglement at nearly room temperature
okay okay so thanks alan thanks for
coming to the talk
um yeah so this is the subject of the
talk a robust quantum entanglement at
room temperature
um okay so let's recall uh schrodinger's
cat
right so we've all heard about this uh
new death experience
uh hysterical german feline so you have
this cat entangled to a pointed vial
uh so if the potential is intact the cat
lives it's opposing violent breaks the
cat is not so fortunate
um so this is a textbook example on how
to explain entanglement
but actually it's kind of a cynical view
of entanglement right this is kind of
shredding his way
of telling us that uh we're likely to
see large-scale microscopic
entanglements
as much as we can kind of see this
creature entangled to a poison vibe
the question is is this cynicism
justified in any way
so when in doubt you blame the coherence
right so let's recall what the coherence
is
so you start with a nice clean pure
state you couple into a heat fast which
is uh the jewelry system
which you have no access to when you let
it thermalize and that would reach
some form of equilibrium uh so the
coherence or uncontrolled symbolization
is usually cited
uh as a root cause we're still not
selling quantum computers by the dozens
or that we can kind of see schrodinger's
cat in real life
so uh when we compare theory to real
life so ideally we'd like to manipulate
your states from any qubit
but uh in reality we're unable to retain
purity as the number of cubes grows
and temperature increases we only get
mixed states
so physically in fact if you think about
you there is actually just
one mixed state this is the thermostat
uh it looks like this you see the minus
beta h over z
where beta is the inverse temperature of
the kappa t where it happens to both
when constants
and h is some hamiltonian could be a
local hamiltonian
and z is a partition function some of
the all of the
exponents of the eigenvalues so
coming back to the question of
entanglement room temperature there's a
kind of an underlying quantum mechanical
question
uh whether entanglement is interesting
fragile afterwards
could it be the case that we are not
supposed to see an angular
temperature in other words it dissipates
into this probabilistic mixture
as the number of cubes grow so now the
challenge would be then to
stabilize the island at room temperature
macroscopic scale
and the technical challenge would be to
design a preferably local hamiltonian
age
for which e to the minus beta h is in
tangent
okay so um we use a necessary condition
for entitlement of property which is
quantum circuit loadout
so let's just recall for a second what
is a quantum circuit something that
looks like this
so you have a product of these d
unitaries where each one is a
gentle product of these two local gates
we have d of those
this is a depth d unitary circuit
and now we can talk about um circuit
complexity so
given the mixed state row uh the surface
complexity of rho
is the minimum integer d for which there
is exists uh a u of delta z
such as if you apply to the o zero uh
which is untangled
and maybe trace out some subsystem of
the qubit
you approach your target state row
system vanishing error
okay so this is circuit complexity and
now you can talk about the falling
conjectures called
robust logical order at room temperature
uh which causes the existence of a local
hamiltonian h
on n qubits that is both uh
topologically ordered in other words
uh uniquely quantum at the ground state
and for beta which is of one the thermal
statement has high circuit complexities
for in other words
the circuit complexity of the thermal
state at constant temperature
diverges fast enough for you to
potentially
able to couple any pair of fuels in your
system
so um truth be told right we we know of
many
local hamiltonians with high
entanglement as a ground state for
example any
quantum aircraft encode was large system
but we don't know of any such
hamiltonian
which the thermal state at high
temperatures retains its circuit low
ground in other words for all we know
a thermal state of quantum mechanical
host
could be stimulatable by a shallow
surface
distribution so the main theorem
that we show here is in fact the
conjecture holds for nearly optimal
parameters in other words
there is this the local hamiltonian
image on a cubit that is
simultaneously logically ordered
in other words it's highly effective at
the ground state and for beta which is
maybe not not a constant but uh always
log log in in other words
the temperature is just almost causing
one of the local events
uh the thermal state has their desired
uh surface collection with slower
boundaries homicide again
okay so in fact we show that more is
true in fact we show that the thermal
state
of this these hamiltonians is locally
decodable to a highly entangled state
in other words the circuit logon that we
saw here is not just
an indication of these long-range
correlations but in fact indication
of quantum dominant code so
in fact this is this establishes that um
it could be the case it's an indication
a thermostat
could be holding a height including
highways with microscopic scale
so let's just give an overview of the
techniques because we don't have a lot
of time
so we first used a quantum locally
testable code
and quantum locally textual codes are
something that translates energies to
errors
and then we consider the thermal state
and show that
uh for high energies you get high
fraction of errors
for low energy to get low frequency and
then
um we use another thing which is to say
well
now we have this unique stage in the
thermal state let's see
what it means on these states and show
that if we analyze the thermal state of
the random error model
and you let the air model evolve under a
hamiltonian which is a quantity locally
then something else exists um not only
do you get
low weight errors low errors can form
large clusters but for specifically for
the circumstance
the low errors become very very sparse
and this is important because in this
region and not in this region
you get another property which is
shallow decoding you can actually apply
a form of
filter stimulant decoder to get from
your thermostat to a quantum air
correcting code
a code space which is highly intended
this allows you to conclude that the
thermal space itself is highly intense
so at the take-home message i would say
we can't assemble into a cat
poisoning sanguine space but if you
allow your hamiltonians to be local but
not
uh especially with kind of baroque
mathematical constructions
uh then you can get quantum systems that
are on one hand
uh truly quantum zero temperature
they're sublogically ordered
and yet uh their entanglement seems to
persist
at very high temperatures really
constant temperatures and decay only
very gradually
um
okay so thanks liara for great talk um
and uh yes i guess we'll move on to uh
williams talk now
uh let me just share my screen
yeah sorry can i get started
uh yeah i think so so i'll just
introduce you so
um next talk is by william kreshmer on
uh
the quantum supremacy it's also
inequality
all right thanks anant um so
recently as in just a little over a year
ago a team at google
announced the first experimental
demonstration of
quantum computational supremacy and they
did it
uh for a problem known as random circuit
sampling so they would
sample a random quantum circuit c here
it's like one and two cubic gates
and um they try to sample from its
output distribution
and the the benchmark they use to verify
their experiment
experiment was uh something known as the
linear cross-entropy
heavy output generation task sometimes
abbreviated x-hog
and basically what it says is their goal
is to produce
n-bit string z such that the probability
of c
and z under like the ideal output
distribution so that's
what this quantity is such that this
quantity is large
and also just a little over a year ago
aronson and gunn proved what is
essentially like a computational analog
of the bell inequality
uh because what they showed is that um
under a plausible complexity theoretic
conjecture
it is hard for a classical algorithm a
polynomial time efficient classical
algorithm
to do substantially better than random
guessing on this benchmark
because this 1 over 2 to the n is what
you get if you just sample the z
uniformly at random because there's
two to the n strings and there's some
probability distribution induced on them
by this
these probabilities and and so this says
that
a classical algorithm can't do much
better than just random guessing
and so when google was able to announce
that they could produce samples that
satisfied roughly
a benchmark of roughly 1.002
over 2 to the n so just slightly larger
than this
this is basically enough for them to
claim quantum
advantage for uh n equals 53 qubits
but this phase is a very natural
question if you
um know of the sarrelson inequality and
quantum
information um we should sort of ask you
know what's the corresponding
um upper bound here for quantum
algorithms so this is
you know the best classical upper bound
for efficient classical algorithms
what's the the best that a fault
quantum computer could do on on this
problem
and it's worth noting that uh if you
assume like a perfect fault tolerant
computer
um that allows you to sample exactly
from c that achieves something like two
over to the on average
um but you know what is that what b is
uh should this be and that's sort of the
the main question we study in this work
and our main result basically says well
uh we study this problem in essentially
the simplest model
uh simplest non-trivial non-trivial
model in which you can say anything
interesting about this question
uh which is in the black box model so
that is we suppose that the circuit c
uh we treat it as a random and qubit
unitary
and we suppose the algorithm has query
access to z
uh and we ask how many queries to see
does this algorithm need to do
substantially better than two over two
to the n on this benchmark and what we
show
is that you need an exponential number
of queries something like at least
2 to the n 4 to do substantially better
than the naive quantum algorithm
that just samples directly from c
we also have some other results in this
paper relating to
other circuit families but this is sort
of the name i'm going to talk about
and there are a few reasons why this is
interesting um the most
obvious one being that it's a lower
bound for
an algorithm that's actually been
implemented in a way
of an actual quantum algorithm um
it's also kind of interesting because it
differs a lot
even in this very restricted query
complexity setting from a lot of the
normal questions we tend to study in
query complexity
uh one way it differs is that it
involves these random unitary oracles
in contrast to um most query complexity
lower bounds which tend to involve
say boolean oracles so you query like an
n-bit string and you get back bits
but here this is sort of inherently a
quantum oracle problem
another way in which this differs a lot
from existing query complexity problems
is that it's not a decision problem
so most query complexity results have to
do with uh
something where the goal is to output a
zero one answer but here the output is
you know
sort of a your output is some end bit
string and you're scored
in in like a continuous way uh based on
on the
probability associated to that input
string uh and basically
uh directly as a result of these two
differences it kind of
immediately requires new tools like um
you know whereas we have good tools in
like the the polynomial method and
the adversary method for lower bound and
quantum query complexity
um pretty much neither of them are
obviously applicable here
so i'll say just a little bit about one
of the tools we introduced to deal with
this
uh and which i think is also maybe the
one that's most likely to be useful
elsewhere
and it has to do with state preparation
oracles
so oftentimes you want to consider
quantum algorithms that have access to
some resource state
some state psi um and so how can we do
this well one way is you can just give
the algorithm copies of psi
but ideally we'd like to say okay well
we want the algorithm to be able to
produce as many copies of psi as it
wants
so let's let's give the algorithm a
unitary u that allows it to produce
copies of psi
and usually the simplest oracle we
consider is what i like to call this
canonical oracle and it's canonical in
the sense that it
um if you have any unitary that lets you
prepare psi then you can also kind of
simulate this unitary
and basically all it does is it swaps
psi and like some fixed state
that i call bot of your choice and then
acts trivially everywhere else
but you can consider other unitary state
preparation oracles
one that turns out to be very natural in
this work is what i call this random
state preparation oracle
so this is a unitary matrix where the
first column contains
psi and what this basically says is that
it gives you back psi
on the all zero as input so you feed in
zero to the n you get psi
but everywhere else this unitary acts
randomly
uh even like car randomly let's say so
um what can we say about you know how
these two compare and power well what we
actually show is that even though these
two resources look very different
from a computational perspective they're
actually essentially equivalent in the
sense that
you could use one to simulate the other
up to like exponential precision
um so i think that's everything i wanted
to say about the
techniques i'll just conclude with a few
open problems um the most obvious one is
to tighten our bounds
so like i said there's this like 2 to
the n over 4 lower bound
and the best upper bound we have is like
2 to the n 3. so there's a gap which
would be nice to close
it would also be nice to give more
evidence this problem is actually hard
in the real world
so like i said for the classical analog
of this problem erinson and gunn did
something
like this they based it on a
you know a particular complexity
assumption but
even their argument doesn't really seem
to work for the the quantum setting so
some some new ideas are probably needed
here
and finally i think it would also just
be interesting to explore
more properties of random quantum
circuits
one assumption that's sort of implicit
in this work is that these random
quantum circuits
exhibit a sort of computational
pseudorandomness property so they're
essentially indistinguishable from the
har measure
um and i don't know if this is this is
true but it you know it seems plausible
and it would nice to be
able to place this assumption on more
solid footing so
um you know giving more evidence for for
such a pseudoanimals properties
is something i would i would be
interested to know more about
and i think i'm about out of time so i
guess i'll end here
uh okay um thanks uh yeah sorry i had my
timer
so um yes uh oops i don't know how to
shut it off
okay well thanks for the great talk um i
think next up
is uh is cheating um so
if you hear you can start the okay
can you see my screen uh yep okay
okay oh thanks silent okay then now i'll
get started
okay okay so hi everyone tuning from
harvard
this is a drawing world with a boss and
shin
and on the spoofing linear cross entropy
initial condensed circuits
yeah so this is very similar to previous
talks on common supremacy
okay so okay so the motivation of common
supremacy is about extended charge 2 in
cc
which state that all the feasible and
efficient computation in a physical
world is in dpt
but we also know that the seminal short
algorithm shows that
factoring actually is in dqp yeah so if
bqp is realizable in the physical world
then it seems that shows the algorithm
already refute
uh the extended charge to insisted but
can this really happen
yeah especially to to demonstrate a
short
algorithm in real world actually we need
roughly about maybe two thousand number
of qubits which is far from current
technology
so in order to study whether a content
device is really uh
implementable in the near future
and also try to see if the extended
church currencies can be refuted in the
near future we need something in the
near-term in the middle
uh try to see if this is the case
and so here uh common computational
supremacy uh
comes up it is like a compromise between
siri
in an experiment yeah and the proposal
of uh content computational supremacy
is to demonstrate the the power of
content computations
like in maybe only like 50 to 100 number
of qubits
and try to show that uh we can really
implement a common computer device
to do that and uh and the classical
harness
like the the casual computer cannot do
that
in a reasonable amount of time and there
are many many proposals like random
circuit sampling both on sampling and
iqp
and today i'm going to focus on one
specific candidate called the random
circuit sampling also mentioned in the
previous talk
used by google okay
so let me quickly uh describe what
random circuit sampling is and using a
two-party uh
communication game so you can think of
there are two parties one is the
challenger and one is approval will
challenge some content skeptics
it will pick uh some unitary gates
for the for the content circuit and
maybe also
take an initial input gate and then the
approver for example google will try to
implement this circuit
and try to sample uh output strings
according to
this random circuit chosen by a
challenger
and then you will send a sample back to
a changer and the change you want to
verify whether the
the distribution of the samples follows
the ideal distribution defined by the
circuit
and intuitively uh it's like without the
continuous approval
probably cannot sample the string follow
the ideal distribution so
this this should only work if the uh if
the
approver can implement the content
device but
the the key uh thing here is like how to
verify
yeah because in order to verify the
sample does follows the
ideal distribution it's kind of like a
chicken and egg issue because you
somehow also need to implement the
common circuits to verify this
okay so the way google chose to do the
verification
is usually something called a linear
cross entropy benchmark
so this is like a variation of whatever
we mentioned before
and you can think of it the linear cost
entropy benchmark of the
linear xcd as a certain statistics
of the distribution p you are sampling
from so this red p
is like the distribution of the approval
example from
so ideally this p should be the
ideal distribution q sub c but
because there are some noise so the
distribution might not be that case
and for distribution p we can define
this value linear xed
and due to a time limit i won't describe
too much on this but the key point is
about the
two two property first is the
completeness
yeah if the distribution p you are
sampling from the ideal distribution qc
then the value will be close to one
which uh in in william setting is like
two over two to the one
yeah here they are different
normalization and the sound is it's like
when the
district when when the p sample from the
uniform distribution which is like you
don't have any
quantum power then the linear fcv should
be close to zero
yeah so the solar communication again of
common supremacy you can think of it as
we want to see whether the prover can
generate the distribution
find final p and having large linear xcv
value
and the computational harness is like if
if the approval don't have quantum
compute common power
then the value should be exponentially
small
good so given this we can quickly see
what google did
so google chose this specific uh 2d
linear
nearest neighbor circuits and they do
qubits from 12 to 53
and then from 14 to 20 and what they did
is
like they can uh they can simulate up to
that fourteen
and then the extrapolatorial result to
death20
and they show that from the
extrapolation they show that they can
achieve
a linear xcv value about like 2.24 times
10 to the minus 3.
so actually it's also far away from one
but they claim that
for classical computer uh to achieve
similar level of linear fcb require ten
thousand years
so this is what google did and uh
we think yeah indeed google did uh made
uh significant problems
but the classical holland site is really
not very solid
specifically the 10 000 years clean on
the technical harness is on the full
simulation of the
common circuits but we know that
actually what they really did is to for
the linear sap test
yeah and also some other group groups
already have some
empirical evidence that this estimation
is highly overestimated
and the linear exhibit itself also not
very well studied
so in this work we want to focus on
trying to understand
if linear activity is really difficult
for technical algorithms
and our answer is a positive
yeah so specifically so reduce your time
limit so i need to be faster
yeah we we observed that a
full simulation might not be necessary
for achieving high linear activity
yeah specifically we can utilize uh
leverage the structure of linear xdb and
circuit structure
and achieve the following steering so
this is a corollary of
our general theory we can design an
algorithm classical algorithm
uh that can like for google's 2d
circuits
if the circuit is shallow like the
deficit slogan then we can
achieve in time two to the d square
positive polynomial time
which is a linear activity value inverse
polynomial
in expectation okay so this is uh
much higher than what google can like
because their hand is based on
exponentially small linear lcd
but the drawback is one that we can okay
yeah sorry yes i'll be quick
it's like we can only do uh look that
okay so since i don't have too much time
so i'll be
very rough on the intuition but the
intuition is to use some
local information that can we can
leverage from
by the low deafness specifically if the
death is short then the marginal of each
output qb can actually be
efficiently estimated and we can use
that
information to bias the sampling
algorithm and achieve high
high linear xt and the intuition of the
theoretical analysis
is through a random work mapping and uh
yeah please go to my long code for more
details and our paper
yeah but to conclude uh yeah we think uh
the google chrome supremacy indeed is a
very important
breakthrough but the classical one is
very less study and
it is very interesting both
theoretically and critically to
study more on this okay thanks for your
attention
thanks for a great talk um i think next
up we have uh
nung kun if he's here
um
i think so right unless there's been a
schedule change
okay maybe he's not here oh he's typing
in chat
oh
on on gather town or
in the cuba day oh okay
uh oh he says he is here
i think he's an attendee instead of a
panelist ah okay
um maybe there's a way you can promote
him
uh promote panelists
another thing you can promote oh yeah
thanks
i think uh i think he's now a panelist
um
hello i'm here hi anna hi uh yeah so do
you want to try
sharing your screen sure sure let me see
yes
uh okay great no problem
so i guess i'll do the introduction so
next talk is sample efficient
um identity testing and independence
testing of quantum states by
couldn't you oh thanks thanks anna so
um i'm not going you from uts thanks uh
for attending my
talk um so property testing was studying
uh this problem for
x in s we want to decide whether x in a
subset of sp
by local queries and for distribution
testing which
study that given samples or observat
observations from one or
more unknown probability distributions
we want to decide whether it satisfies a
certain model
and for property testing usually we want
to study
of distributions we want to see that
whether for
x in s we want to decide whether x in p
or x
is outside q with high probability
and distribution testing many important
problems has been extensively studied by
tcs community for instance the identity
testing
independence testing and conditional
independence testing
well many smart ideas and techniques
based on the l2 norm analysis
for quantum property testing we are
focusing on this problem given copies of
from one or more
unknown quantum states we want to decide
whether it is satisfies a certain
property
this problem was initialized by however
1970s
different from classical classical
property testing a great variety of
measurement we need to consider
so for the jointman joint measurement
setting
we are giving n copies of the
dimensional quantum state row and
property p
um we want to uh we want to design a
giant measurement
and apply on n copies of rho
simultaneously and output the data
well data characterized that whether row
is in p or
outside p with high probability
for independent measurement setting
sorry we want to design measurement
apply on each copies of row and
gathering all the classical output
together to a classical computer c and
compute data
so comparing these two methods joint
measurement
might have low complexity and
but the implementation is very hard even
in the future because
the dimension we need to consider is
like d to the k
k is the number of copies and you for
many questions
k has to be probably d
and quantum property testing has been
widely studied for instance the
tomography problem output a good
estimation of given state
spectrum testing output a good
estimation of the spectrum of given
state adding testing and shadow transfer
online learning
but there's you can see there's a
there's a gap between classical
simulation
classical property testing and quantum
property testing classical property
testing only have one sampling
method which is called counting but
quantumly usually we were using sure
about duality to achieve
um small uh sample complexity
therefore many smart ideas and
techniques of classical property testing
are not used in quantum property testing
in this work we um
describe an independent measurement
which preserves the autonom
of quantum state so
the formal statement is as follows for
the dimensional column system there's a
deterministic uh there's a measurement m
such that the output is a resulting
probability distribution p and q
for any two columns they run sigma
satisfy this
this equation that the two norm between
p and q
equals the two norm between row and
sigma divided d plus one
at the same time the true norm of p and
two norm of q
is no more than square two divided b
plus one
now we can have this framework to solve
the general quantum property testing
problem
for quantum property testing problem of
l1 norm we first
apply our measurement to transfer it
into the property testing problem of
classical distributions
and then we call the classical algorithm
for l2 norm and use the relation
back to a quantum organism for l2 norm
and then
and applying the relation between l2
norm and l1 and we solve our original
problem
so using this method we have so
many problems so for where in
this talk i'll focus on the identity
testing
um using independent measurement and the
joint measurement lower bound for
independent setting testing
so for ident testing we want to
distinguish rho equals sigma and the one
norm distance between row and sigma is
greater than epsilon
we can use independent measurement um to
solve this problem using uh d squared
divided some square copies
is very simple because after applying
our measurement
uh we we we have this probability
distribution uh
p and q which satisfies the equation on
the right hand side
and then we just recall the result of
cdbv which showed that
ob divided square epsilon square copies
of p
and q uh can solve the problem that
can distinguish p equals q and the two
norm between p
and q is greater than epsilon if p is
the maximum
of the two norm between a p two norm of
p
and two number of q so just plug in is
all right
and for independence testing problem we
have we're
we're working on a multi-party quantum
state
so says row one two is called
independent if row one two
is row one times zero two and our goal
is to distinguish whether row one two is
row one times zero two or
row one two uh the difference between
row and two and any sigma one times
sigma two is greater than zero for any
quantum stage sigma 1 and sigma 2.
we actually only need to distinguish
rule 1 case that rho 1 2 equals to rho 1
times 0 2 from the case that rho 1 2
minus rho 1 times rho 2 is greater than
newton's divided 3. so
we'll um because we are um so we will
we only care about the ladder case and
the problem is simple because we can
call identity testing
in the sense that for for a given copy
of row one two we can
generate row one by tracing on row row
two and we can also
another copy of row one two we can
generate row two by tracing out rule one
so then we only need to verify whether
row one two equals zero one ten zero two
alpha from each other
and the similar ideas for identity as
identity testing of
uh iodine testing of collections and
independence of collections and
condition intense testing of quantum
classical class uh
classical quantum quantum state
now we want to show the lower bound for
joint measurement to
to uh for the problem of independence
testing
so one can uh our result is that uh on
a sigma okay thanks
so we want to show that d1 tends to d2
divide epsilon square copies are needed
for the independent testing in d1 d2
system
so if d1 and d2 are very large we can
just employ the
independence test thing to test whether
rule 1 2
equals to i1 divided d1 times i2 divided
d2
by first test where the row 1 is at what
i1 divide d1
and then test whether row 2 is i2
divided d2 then test the independence of
r12
and we only need to recall that result
by um
by o'donnell and john wright says that
uh
100 1.15 d divided some square copies
are necessary to distinguish whether
row is maximum mixed but this method
does not work for large d1 and small d2
because step one here already uh
use the same order as the maximum mixed
testing
our method is using dimension splitting
so we just
split it to general two by d system into
a log d q b system and then we test
whether each qubit is a maximum mix
and then we test whether row is
independent
through the one versus log d cut
and the main technique is here though we
want to uh is
m plus one cubic state if some close to
b independent from any one
versus m partition then it is five
m epsilon close to b m plus one parted
independent and then we solve the
problem
thank you very much hey thanks
uh thanks for another great talk and the
last talk
is by uma so i guess um
if you want to stop your screen share
so stop sharing
sorry maybe i'll just leave
okay looks good so um
yes the last talk will be by it'll be by
uma greece on quantum versus randomized
communication complexity with efficient
players
thanks hamil this is based on the joint
work with rand raz and avi shaital
the setting is communication complexity
so there is a function that takes as
input two binary strings and it outputs
a bit
alice gets one of the strings and bob
gets the other string and their goal is
to compute this
function and they want to do so while
minimizing the amount of communication
between them
note that a trivial protocol is to have
alice send her entire input to bob
this costs n bits of communication so we
are interested in small cost protocols
that is protocols that do much better
than this
protocols that have cost poly
logarithmic in the input size
in this talk we'll be interested in
partial functions that is
functions that are defined on a subset
of points and alice and bob only need to
solve
this function on that subset of points
this is the general setting of
communication complexity
we're interested in the following two
models the first is the classical
randomized model
where alice and bob share public coins
and their goal is to compute the
function with high probability
while minimizing the worst case number
of qubits number of bits that they
exchange
in the quantum setting there are two
differences the first is that alice and
bob share epr pairs
the second is that they can exchange
qubits as before their goal is to
compute this function with high
probability
while minimizing the number of qubits
that they exchange
we're also interested in the number of
rounds in two-way communication alice
and bob can interact with each other
in one-way communication alice sends a
message to bob and bob has to decide
whether the function is zero or one
in simultaneous communication alice and
bob don't talk to each other
instead there is a third party charlie a
referee to whom alice and bob
send messages charlie upon receiving the
messages has to decide whether the
function is
0 or 1. these are successively weaker
models
that is there are functions that are
easy in two-way communication but hard
for one-way communication
similarly functions that are easy in the
one-way model but hard in the
simultaneous model
the main problem of interest is this is
there a communication problem that has a
small
cost quantum protocol but no small cross
classical protocol
is there a function that's easy to
communicate when you can exchange qubits
but exponentially harder when you can
only exchange classical bits
does quantum provide advantage in the
world of communication complexity
for total functions this is a major open
question
we don't know the answer to this for
partial functions on the other hand
there is a long line of research
spanning over 20 years
all of which demonstrates in various
ways that quantum communication
can provide advantages the first such
result was
shown by booming cleveland bidderson
they show that in the zero error setting
when you want to answer correctly with
probability one
there are functions that are easy in the
quantum simultaneous model but hard in
the classical two-way model
so this is saying that a rather weak
model of quantum communication
can exponentially outperform a rather
strong model of classical communication
in the bounded error setting when we
want to answer correctly with high
probability
the first such result was shown between
quantum two-way and
randomized to a this was strengthened in
various ways
and the state-of-the-art result is this
which is that quantum simultaneous when
alice and bob share entanglement
can exponentially outperform a
randomized 2a
so let us state this result more
formally this is due to govindsky
this is the state-of-the-art result and
it essentially subsumes most of the
previous bounded error separations
so governs demonstrates a partial
function which has a small cost protocol
in the quantum simultaneous model
when alice and bob share a few epr pairs
however there is no randomized protocol
of small cost
regardless of the number of rounds this
is the state of the art result
now one drawback of this result in the
context of our work
is that this protocol is not efficient
so what do we mean by an efficient
protocol so we say that a quantum
protocol is efficient
if it can be implemented by a quantum
circuit of small size with oracle access
to the inputs
so roughly speaking this means two
things the first is that
everything that alice bob and charlie do
can be implemented by
quantum circuits of small size in other
words the amount of work they do
to prepare and process their messages is
not too large compared to the size of
the messages that they're sending
the second is that the oracle access to
the input it just
means that alice bob don't need to read
their inputs bit by bit
instead they can make a few queries to
their input in superposition and still
be able to execute the protocol
the quantum protocol in this theorem is
not efficient
because charlie the referee needs to
perform in many measurements one after
the other
and this seems to be really crucial for
the lower bound to hold
so we ask this question does is there a
separation where the quantum protocol is
efficient
our work addresses this so we show that
there is a partial function which has an
efficient
small cost quantum simultaneous protocol
when alice and bob share a few epr pairs
however there is no randomized protocol
of small cost regardless of the number
of rounds
so in other words we qualitatively
recover govinsky separation
between quantum simultaneous and two-way
randomized
furthermore everything that all
everything that the players do in our
quantum
protocol can be implemented by small
circuits
with oracle access to the input so this
is our result
let me briefly talk about what was known
about efficient separations
to the best of our knowledge efficiency
has not been explicitly addressed in the
world of quantum versus classical
separations in fact in most of the
previous separations that i mentioned
the quantum parties are inefficient
nevertheless there was an efficient
separation known between
quantum two-way and randomized two-way
so this follows by applying query to
communication
lifting theorems to existing efficient
query complexity separations
our work kind of unites these two
aspects of
quantum classical separations so one we
show a separation between the
the state-of-the-art separation which is
between quantum simultaneous and
randomized two-way
secondly the all the parties in our
quantum protocol are
efficient another aspect of our work is
that we provide a new lower bound
technique for
randomized communication complexity
based on fourier analytic techniques
from these two works so the first is the
polarizing random vox result of
chatopathy at all
the second is the oracle separation of
bqp and ph
due to ras and tal in the remaining time
let me just
describe the function for which our
separation holds
so without going into too many details
let me say that our function
is based on the correlation function
which was first introduced by aaronson
who showed that estimating the
correlation is easy with quantum queries
but hard with randomized queries so we
take a variant of this correlation
function and lift it to the
communication world
using xor as the gadget so this is the
correlation communication problem where
alice and bob want to find out whether
the xor of their inputs has high
correlation or growth formulation
our main theorem is that this function
is has an efficient protocol in the
quantum simultaneous model
whereas there is no small cost protocol
in the classical randomized model
uh one minute oh okay thanks yeah
so just to say a little bit about the
proof technique we make use of the
correlation distribution as defined in
the oracle separation result of pqp and
ph due to razanthal
so we first rephrase our problem in
their framework
now doing so allows us to use their
machinery which says that
instead of so it reduces the task of
proving this lower bond to proving
a upper bound on the level to fourier
mass of a certain function
so that is the second part of our the
technical heart of our work
we show that the level to fourier mass
of a function associated with a small
cost
protocol is bounded so this is all i
want to say about the proof technique
um i guess i finished a little early so
let me just
show you the open questions here and
finish
okay well uh thanks for for the talk and
thanks to all the speakers
for speaking this session so now we have
some time for a q a and for general
panel discussion
so if you have a question for any of the
speakers or something that
you want to address to all the speakers
feel free to unmute yourself and
ask or you can type in the chat or the q
a if you prefer
um i had a question for the first
speaker
um and so
you said something about uh i i think
this was leer
um you said something about um
i might have made a mistake but
something along the lines of like
uh simple if since thermal state is like
locally decodable or like simply
decodable to like a quantum error
correcting code state
by like sip seriously something like sip
serving you said then like
the the thermal state must have been
like what's it
entangled or something like that and i
was wondering if you could elaborate on
that but since i i don't quite follow
the logic there
uh yeah yeah sure so this is kind of
like uh uh just
composing the depth of the circuit so if
you have a quantum aircraft in code
then um any code state uh
even like the uniformly mixed state over
all code states
uh is highly tangled in a well-defined
way right because
um you can just show kind of a litecoin
argument that means like logarithms that
now um specifically for
inverse temperature which is one of the
levels with hamiltonian
constructor then um you can show that
the errors fall clusters which are at
most say logarithmic
so if you apply sister spin on decoding
you can kind of
completely annihilate the error in depth
which is load logging
and so in other words being as if you
reverse the depth
row know you could have generated the
thermostat by applying uh a log log and
the circuit over a log end that channel
which means that overall the circuit
that
is with him so this is the kind of
argument that was used there okay i
think
okay i think i follow thank you
so by the way leor it looks like there's
a question in the q a from unrug about
whether the log log and temperature is
due to the current
uh qltc parameters
oh i think the question is what did the
log log n temperature
in your result is that does that follow
from like the current best known
parameters on qltcs
oh yeah yeah this uh this is kind of
like um
it depends on from the topology uh
so right like this is kind of like a
clash between two forces
uh you need on one hand good quantum
locally testable code
and on the other hand you want the
topology to be such that
if you look examine like do me into the
small segments of cubes
it's it has a good departure expansion
in terms of
keywords to constrain now
um the point is that
the construction only allows for this to
hold for log
n size 10. uh if you can push this
higher to you know standing over linear
sets then you would be in a much better
shape if to push
up the temperature i think it's a matter
of finding the right topology
right so it's hard like even classically
if you have something which is both
canon graph default expander and quantum
level festival
so yeah this is like an open question
let's see thanks
maybe i can ask a question too i think
mainly cheening but also william might
have thoughts on this is
uh i guess so your result shows that
um for circuits of a fairly short depth
you can like spoof this uh this
cross-entropy benchmark
um quite a bit shorter than the actual
depth of like the google circuits
release um
it's like do you know do you have like
any thoughts like what like the depth
threshold might be where things start
getting hard
to to spoof
yeah thanks for a question so that's all
the
so we are using exactly the same
algorithm then indeed there will be a
limit
but actually in the in the follow-up
work we are actually trying to
um design uh other variants of the
algorithm using similar ideas
yeah like creating some defects in the
circuits etc
and and we can we can we are able to
handle much larger
depth circuits but the theoretical
analysis is much more difficult
yeah so for that follow-up we are mainly
working on
in empirical uh simulation to try to
really see
what being executed we can achieve
and for now it's hard to say like it's
actually very delicate
yeah like the the algorithm still can
achieve non-trivial
uh linear xzb using similar ideas but
uh it's unclear what they're scaling
yeah because i said like
google this kind of verification is very
expensive
so it's actually very difficult to do
simulation so we actually need to use
google cloud
to try to study google com supremacy um
i mean wasn't there a recent result um
it was by fernando brando and some other
people
showing that like a certain level of
depth is needed
even just for um to guarantee that
quantum circuits anti-concentrate
and that's basically the assumption you
need to get that um
the linear cross-entropy output
probabilities
are distributed nicely um
so presume i i guess i would guess
the depth would be to be at least that
that's only login so right
yeah i don't remember what the constant
is but yeah
um but i also wouldn't be surprised if
it needs to be much larger than log n
uh-huh i see and i guess the google duck
by the way
is like square root n if i'm remembering
correctly is that yeah
i mean it's so hard to say because it's
all constant but i guess yeah yeah
i mean they want you to n is n is 53 and
depth was like 20 i believe so
right and i think
also intuitively like the the xcv
achieved by
google is also actually exponential is
that maybe two to the minus
cn sct expansion in depth for some
constant c
and our algorithm also roughly maybe two
to minus c
prime d so india is really comparing the
x
uh constant exponents and
then it's not very clear like because
for different circuits or architectures
and even different ensembles have
different
content and like is the exponential in
their result that's just from like
the constant error rate per gate or
something you'd expect it to
see so that does sound very delicate
i had a question true i was wondering if
you could say some words about
um like you you mentioned that you
you're like
part of your technical work is like this
bound on the fourier mass of the second
level of
some functions so i was wondering like
what if you could maybe state
just like what that what what the what
the bound you're able to achieve isn't
like on what type of functions it
applies
sure um so so let's say the protocol is
c of x y where x is alice's input and y
is bob's input and
c is the output of the protocol so
um so we consider the following function
which is expectation of
c of x y where x x or y equals
z so take a random pair of inputs
x comma y for alice and bob conditioned
on their xor b
equal to z and look at the expected
value of the protocol
so that look at the expected output when
the inputs are sampled according to this
distribution
so this is a function of x x or y and
we bound the level two mass of fourier
mass of this function
by the cost of the protocol so by level
two fourier mass i mean sum of
ah mod of f hat s where s is of size two
so sum of mod of level two fourier
coefficients is at most the cost of the
protocol
so um so actually we bound this by cost
square
and this is why we get the n to the one
fourth bond
lower bound so
okay so and then uh and then the pass
from like the second level fourier mass
upper bound
to or rather the lower bound of the cost
to
like this thing is like just is other
stuff that's quite hard to explain right
now
it's hard to describe shortly but this
is kind of the bulk of the work of
uh horrible separation result and thank
you okay
sure
oh wait sorry uh one quick thing so like
if you were to if you were able to get
like upper bound of cost then would you
get like
uh well i don't know it would be able to
get redone
exactly
i also have a question for uma um
so you know one of the main um
contributions of your work is this
the the players in this exponential
separation like the ones that have the
smaller complexity are actually
efficient that their complexity
if you view the input at least as a
query input is is of similar
um complexity similar to the amount of
communication
log versus polyurethane exponential
has this notion of uh and you also
mentioned this notion of efficient
players hasn't been considered before in
the quantum
context like the quantum versus question
uh
are there other contexts where people
study this question like for example in
just like a randomized versus
deterministic
um probably only in the context of
interactive proofs i remember it but
probably not in separations as far as i
remember um
when you have things like equality which
kind of demonstrate this so i guess it's
efficient in the randomized world but
hard in the classical world
a deterministic world so why is
is the protocol for equality also
efficient or randomized
i guess um
[Music]
these hash functions i think it might
the way i think about it is you
interpret it with a random string so
that that's
inefficient yeah so um
yeah that's a good question i don't
think it's been explicitly addressed in
uh separating models the only context
i've seen it is in
interactive groups and things like that
thanks
i maybe have a question for leor but
also the next session is about to start
so
those who want to switch over uh should
feel free to do that
um but uh my question for leora is just
um
i remember there's so so your theorem
statement has these two conditions right
that there's like
you want the hamiltonian to have
topological order
uh for the ground state and then you say
you also have like circuit complexity in
the
unlike mixed states but like i mean
there's some discussion of like you
could take the hamiltonian for a
classical code and look at the
the give state of that and like you know
that that might already have like
highest complexity so um right right so
yeah
so yes the conjecture is kind of stated
to rule this out right so if you have
like
let's let's just say this right so if
you have a classical
ltc uh with large like for the new
difference right with the third search
code
uh then yeah it's hard to sample from
distribution
so um you need like a log
n surface complexity uh but
so then the first condition of the
conjecture calls for you to have some
quantum
entanglement actual constant angle at
zero temperature
and that you cannot achieve with with a
classical uh lcc
so so the idea is right so you start off
with a quantum just like
the ideas you start with a quantum state
which is entangled then you let it
thermalize
and then you you know you come back and
check on your state and see if it's
still entangled after a long while
and if you succeed in that experiment
maybe like you have
did i answer your question yeah yeah i
think so yeah at least
um is this clear why i i i like this
this picture of like you start in the
ground see and let it thermalize
that makes it seem like a nice yeah i
mean this is like this
this is what the simple state does right
which is something for more victoria
then you can ask whether this
that was entangled or not yeah
um
well uh are there any other questions or
or should we
close the session to the next room
i guess not so um well round of applause
for all the speakers
and uh yeah thanks